all right today's topic is distributed
transactions and these come in really to
implementation pieces and that's how
I'll cover them the first big piece of
concurrency control the second is atomic
commit and the reason why distributive
transactions come up is that it's very
frequent for people with large amounts
of data to end up splitting or sharding
the data over many different servers so
maybe if you're running a bank for
example the bank balances for half your
customers are one server and the bank
balances for the other half are on a
different server let's do it like split
the load both the processing load and
the space requirements this comes up for
other things too maybe you're recording
vote counts on articles at a website you
know the maybe there's so many millions
millions of articles half the vote
counts are and are on one server and
half the vote cancer or another but some
operations require touching modifying or
reading data on multiple different
servers so if we're doing a bank
transfer from one customer into another
well their balances may be on different
servers and therefore in order to do the
balance we have to modify data read and
write data on two different servers and
we'd really like to or one way building
these systems and we'll see others later
on in the course one way to build the
system just try to hide the complexity
of splitting this data across multiple
servers try to hide it from the
application programmer and this is like
traditionally has been a database
concern for for many decades and so a
lot of today's material originated with
databases but the ideas have been used
much more widely in distributed systems
which you wouldn't necessarily call a
traditional database the way people sort
of usually package up concurrency
control plus
atomic commit is in abstraction called a
transaction which we've seen before and
the idea is that the programmer you know
has a bunch of different operations may
be on different records in the database
they'd like all those operations to be
sort of a single unit and not split by
failures or by observation from other
activities and the transaction
processing system will require the
programmer to mark the beginning and the
end of that sequence of reading and
writing and updating operations in order
to mark the beginning and of the
transaction and the transaction
processing system has certainly will
provide certain guarantees about what
happens between the beginning and the
end
so for example supposing we're running
our bank and we want to do a transfer
from account of user X to the account of
user wide now these balances from both
of them start out as 10 so initially
expose 10 y equals 10 and x and y I'm
mean to be records in a database and we
want to transfer we will actually
imagine that there's two transactions
that might be running at the same time
one to transfer a dollar from account X
to account Y and the other transaction
to do an audit of of all the accounts at
the bank to make sure that the total
amount of money in the bank never
changes because after all if you do
transfers you know the total shouldn't
change even if you move money between
accounts in order to express this with
transactions we might have two
transactions the first transaction call
it t1 is the transfer well mark the
programmer is expected to mark the
beginning of it with the begin
transaction which all right at the
beginning and then the operations on the
two balances on the two records in the
database so we might add
[Music]
one might add one the balance X and add
-1 to Y and then we need to mark the end
by the transaction currently we might
have a transaction that's going to check
all the balance do an audit of all the
balances find the sum or look at all the
balances make sure they add up to the
number that doesn't change despite
transfers so the second transaction I'm
thinking about the audit transaction
also we need to mark the beginning and
end this time we're just reading there's
a read-only transaction we need to get
the current balances of all the accounts
lists they were just these two accounts
for now so we have two temporary
variables we're gonna read the first one
it's going to be the value of balance X
just right get to mean we're reading
that record we also read Y and we print
them both and that's the end of the
transaction the question is what are
legal results from these two
transactions that's the first thing we
want to establish is what are you know
given the starting state namely the two
balances for ten dollars and what could
be the final results after you've run
both these transactions maybe at the
same time so we need a notion of what
would be correct and once we know that
we need to be able to build machinery
that will actually be able to execute
these transactions and get only those
correct answers despite concurrency and
failures so first what's correctness
well databases usually have a notion of
correctness called acid
or bb-8 is acid and it stands for atomic
and this means that a transaction that
has multiple steps
you know maybe writes multiple different
records if there's a failure despite
failures either all of the right should
be done or none of them it shouldn't be
the case that a failure at an awkward
time in the middle of a transaction
should leave half the updates completed
invisible and half the updates never
done it's all or nothing so this is or
not despite failures the C stands for
consistent it's actually we're not going
to worry about that that's usually meant
to refer to the fact that database will
enforce certain invariants declared by
the application it's not really our
concern today the I though it's quite
important it usually stands for isolated
and this is a really a property of
whether or not two transactions that run
at the same time can see each other's
changes before the transactions have
finished whether or not they can see
sort of intermediate updates and from
the middle of another transaction and
your goal is no and the sort of
technical specific thing that most
people generally mean by isolation is
that the transaction execution is
serializable and I'll explain what that
means in a bit but it boils down to
transactions can't see each other's
changes can't see intermediate states
but only complete transaction results
and the final D stands for durable
and this means that after a transaction
commits after the client or whatever
program that submitted the transaction
gets a reply back from the database
saying yes
you know we've executed your transaction
the D in acid means that the
transactions modifications the database
will be durable that they'll still be
there they won't be erased by a some
sort of failure and in practice that
means that stuff has to be written into
some non-volatile storage persistent
storage like a disk and so today you are
in fact for this whole course really our
concerns are going to revolve around
good behavior with respect to failure
good respect good behavior with respect
to other from multiple parallel
activities and making sure that the data
is there still they are after even if
something crashes so the most
interesting part of this for us is the
specific definition of ice of isolated
or serializable so I'm going to lay that
out before before talking about how it
actually applies to these transactions
so the ioan isolated is usually and the
definition for this if a set of
transactions executes you know
concurrently more or less at the same
time they you are the set of results and
here the results refer to both the new
database records created by any
modifications the transactions might do
and in addition any output that the
transaction is produced so broader
transactions these two adds since they
change records their needs change
records are part of the results and the
output of this print statement is part
of the results so the definition of
serializable says the results are
serializable
if there exists some order of execution
of the transactions so we're gonna say a
specific execution parallel concurrent
execution of transactions is
serializable if there exists some serial
order really emphasizing serial here a
serial order of execution of those same
transactions that yields the same result
as the actual execution and the
difference of here is the actual
execution may have had a lot of
parallelism in it but it's required to
produce the same result as some one at a
time
execution of the same transactions and
so the way you check whether an
execution is serializable whether some
concurrent execution is serializable is
you look at the results and see if you
can find actually some one at a time
execution of the same transactions that
does produce the same results so for our
transaction up here there's only two
orders there's only two one at a time
serial orders available transaction 1
then transaction 2 or transaction 2 then
transaction 1 and so we can just look at
the results that they would produce if
executed one at a time in each of these
orders so if we execute t1 and then t2
then we get x equals 11
why equals 9 and this print statement
since t1 executed first this print
statement sees these two updated values
and so it will print the string 11 9 the
other possible order is that perhaps t2
ran first and then t1 and in that case
t2 will see that 2 records before they
were modified but the modifications will
still take place since t1 runs later so
the final results will again be x equals
11 y equal 9 but this time t2 sodded
before our values so these are the two
legal results for serializability and if
we ever see anything else from running
these two transactions at the same time
we'll know that the database were
running against does not provide
serializable execution it's doing
something else and so while we're
thinking through what would happen if or
what would happen if will always be
against these AHA these are the only two
legal results we better be doing
something that produces one or the other
it's interesting to note that there's
more than one possible result depending
on the actual order you if you you
submit these two transactions at the
same time you don't know whether it's
gonna be t1 t2 or t2 t1 so you have to
be willing to expect more than one
possible legal result and as you have
more or transactions running
concurrently a more complicated there
may be many many possible different
correct results that are all
serializable because of many many orders
here that could be used to fulfill this
requirement okay so now that we have a
definition of correctness and we even
know what all the possible results are
we can ask a few questions so few
what-if questions about how these could
execute so for example suppose that the
way the system actually executed this
was that it started transaction 2 and
got as far as
just after reading X and then
transaction one ran at this point and
then after transaction one finished
transaction to continue executing now it
turns out in with different other
transactions than this that might
actually be legal but here we want to
know if it's legal so we're wondering
gosh if we actually executed that way
what results will we get and are they
the same as either of these two well if
we execute transaction one here then t1
is gonna see value 10 t2 is gonna see
the value after decrementing Y so t1
will be 10 t2 will be 9 and what this
print will be 10 9 and that's neither of
these two outputs here so that means
executing in this way that I just drew
is not serializable it would not be
legal another interesting question is
what if we started executing transaction
1 and we got as far as just after the
first ad and then at that point all the
transaction 2 executed right here so
that would mean at this point X is value
11 the transaction 2 would read 1110 now
print 1110 and 1110 is not one of these
two legal values so this execution is
also not legal for these two
transactions
so the reason why serializable
serializability is a popular and useful
definition of what it means for
transactions to be correct for execution
of transactions to be correct is that
it's a very easy model for programmers
you can write complicated transactions
without having to worry about what else
may be running in the system there may
be lots of other transactions may be
using the same date as you may be
reading trying to read and write it at
the same time there might be failures
who knows but the guarantee here is that
it's safe to write your transactions as
if nothing else was happening because
the final results have to be as if your
transaction was executed by itself in
this one-at-a-time order which is a very
simple very nice programming model it's
also nice that this definition allows
truly parallel execution of transactions
as long as they don't use the same data
so we run into trouble here because
these two transactions are both reading
x and y but if they were using
completely disjoint database records
they could it turns out this definition
allows you to build a database system
that would execute transactions to use
disjoint data completely in parallel and
if you are a sharded system which is
what we're sort of working up to today
with the data different data is on
different machines you can get true
parallel speed-up because maybe one
transaction executes Spira in the first
shard on the first machine and the other
in parallel on the second machine so
there are opportunities here for for
good performance before I dig into how
to implement serializable transactions
there's one more small point I want to
bring up it turns out that one of the
things we need to be able to cope with
is that transactions may for one reason
or another
basically fail or decide to fail in the
middle of the transaction and this is
usually called an abort and you know for
many transaction systems we need to be
prepared to handle Oh what should happen
if a transaction tries to access a
record that doesn't exist or divides by
zero or maybe you know since some
transaction implementation schemes use
locking maybe a transaction causes a
locking deadlock and the only way to
break the deadlock is to kill one of one
or more of the transactions this
participating in the deadlock so one of
the things that's going to be kind of
hanging in the background and will come
up is the necessity of coping with
transactions that all of a sudden in the
middle decide they just cannot proceed
and you know maybe really in the middle
after they've done some work and started
modifying things we need to be able to
kind of back out of these transactions
and undo any modifications they've made
all right
the implementation strategy for
transactions for these asset
transactions I'm gonna split into two
big pieces but and talk about both of
them the main topics in the lecture the
first big implementation topic is
concurrency control this is the main
tool we use to provide serializability
the current or isolation so concurrency
control bias
by its isolation from other concurrent
transactions that might be trying to use
the same data and the other big pieces I
mentioned is atomic commit and this is
what's going to help us deal with the
possibility that oh yeah this
transactions executing a long and it's
may be modified X and then all of a
sudden there's a failure and one of the
server's involved but other servers that
were maybe actually in other parts of
the transaction that is if x and y are
in different machines we need to be able
to recover even if there's a partial
failure of only some of the machines the
transactions running off and the big
tool people use for that is this atomic
commit you'll talk about all right so
first concurrency control there's really
two classes two major approaches to
concurrency control I'll talk about both
during the course if they're just mean
strategies the first strategy is a
pessimistic usually called pessimist
pessimistic concurrency control and this
is usually locking we've all done
locking in the labs in the context of go
program so it turns out databases
transaction processing systems also used
locking and the idea here is U is the
same as well you're quite familiar with
this that before transaction uses any
data it needs to acquire a lock on that
data and if some other transactions
already using the data the lock will be
held and we'll have to wait before we
can acquire the lock wait for the other
transaction to finish and in pessimistic
systems if there's locking conflicts
somebody else has the lock it'll cause
delays so you're sort of treating
performance for correctness the other
main approach is optimistic approaches
the basic idea here is you don't worry
about whether maybe some other
transactions reading or writing the data
at the same time as you you just go
ahead and do whatever reads and writes
you're gonna do although typically into
some sort of temporary area and then
only at the end you go and check whether
actually maybe some other transaction
might have been interfering and if
there's no other transaction now you're
done and you never had to go through any
of the overhead or weighting of taking
out locks the locks are reasonably
expensive to manipulate but if somebody
else was modifying the data in a
conflicting way at the same time you
were then you have to abort that
transaction and we try and the
abbreviation for this is often
optimistic concurrency control um it
turns out that under different
circumstances these two strategies one
can be faster than the other
if conflicts are very frequent you
probably actually want to use
pessimistic concurrency control not
because of conflicts are frequent you're
gonna get a lot of aborts due to
conflicts for optimistic seems if
complex are rare than optimistic
concurrency control can be faster
because it completely avoids locking
overhead today will be all about
pessimistic concurrency control and then
some later paper in particular farm in a
couple weeks we'll deal with an
optimistic scheme okay so today talking
about pessimistic schemes refers
basically to locking and in particular
for today the reading was about
two-phase locking which is the most
common type of locking
and the idea in two-phase locking for
transactions is that transactions gonna
use a bunch of Records like X&Y and our
example the first rule is that you
acquire a lock before using date any
piece of data we're reading or writing
any record and the second rule for
transactions is that a transaction must
hold any locks it acquires until after
it commits or aborts you're not allowed
to give up locks in the middle of the
transaction you have to hold them all
you can only accumulate them until
you're done until after you're done so
until Phoebe done so this is two-phase
locking the phases are the phases which
we acquire locks and then phase in which
we just hold onto them until we're done
so for two phase locking to sort of see
why locking works your typical locking
systems well there's a lot of variation
typical locking systems associate a
separate lock with each record in the
database with each row in each table for
example although they can be more more
coarse-grained these transactions start
out holding no locks let's say
transaction one starts out holding no
locks when it first uses X before so
I'll have to use it it has to acquire
the lock on X and it may have to wait
and when it first uses Y it acquires
another lock the lock on Y when it
finishes after it's done becoming these
both if we ran both these transactions
at the same time they're gonna basically
race to get the lock on X and whichever
of them gets the managed to get the lock
on X first it will proceed and finish
and commit meantime the other
transaction that didn't manage to get
the lock on X first it's going to see if
you're waiting before it what you does
anything with accent OA can acquire the
lock so transaction 2 actually got the
lock first
you would get the value of X get the
value of y cuz transaction one hasn't
gotten at this point hasn't locked Y yet
it'll print and it will finish and
release its locks and only then
transaction one will be able to acquire
the lock on X and as you can see that
basically forces a serial order because
it forced in this case it force the
order T two and then when T two finishes
only then T 1 so with it's explicitly
forcing an order which causes the that
execution to follow the definition of
serializability that you know really is
executing T 2 to completion and only
then T 1 so we do get correct execution
all right so one question is why you
need to hold the locks until the
transactions completely finished you
might think that you could just hold a
lock while you are actually using the
data and that would be more efficient
and indeed it would that is you know
maybe only hold the lock for the period
of time in which t2 is actually looking
at record X or maybe only hold the lock
on X here for the duration of the add
operation and then immediately release
it and in that case that what if we
transaction one immediately released a
lock on X there there by disobeying this
rule of course but if it immediately
release the lock on X then transaction
two might be able to start a little bit
earlier we get more concurrency more
higher performance so this rule
definitely you know bad for performance
so we want to make pretty sure that it's
it's good for that's required for
correctness
so what won't happen if transactions did
actually release locks as early as
possible
so suppose t2 here reads X and then
immediately releases this lock on X that
would allow t1 since at now at this
point in the execution t2 doesn't hold
any locks because it's just released it
illegally release the lock on X since it
holds a no locks that means t1 could
completely execute right here and we
already knew from from before that this
interleaving is not correct as it
doesn't produce either these two outputs
similarly if if t1 released this lock on
X after finished adding one to X that
would allow all of t2 to slip in right
here and we know also from before that
that results in in illegal results
there's a an additional kind of problem
that can come up with releasing locks
after modifying data if t1 were to
release the lock on X it might allow t2
to see the modified version of X here to
see the X after adding 1 to it and to
print that output and then for tteyuu to
complete after printing the incremented
value of x if transaction one were to
abort after that point maybe because
bank balance Y doesn't exist or maybe
bank bonds Y exists but its balance is
zero and you know we're not allowed to
decrement 0 for bank balances because
that's an overdraft so t1 might modify X
then abort and part of the abort has to
be undoing its update to X in order to
maintain atomicity and what that would
mean if it released the locks is that
transaction 2 would have seen this sort
of phantom value of 11 that went away
because t1 aborted you would have seen a
value that according to the rules never
existed right because then the
transaction 1 aborts then it's as if it
never existed and so that means the
results from t2 had better be as if t2
ran by itself without t1 at all but if
it sees the increment that it's gonna
print 11 for X 11 10 actually which is
just doesn't correspond to any state in
the database given that t1 didn't really
complete okay so that's why those are
two dangers that are averted due to
violations serialize ability that are
averted because transactions hold the
locks until they're done a further thing
to note about these rules or that it's
very easy for them to produce deadlock
so you know for example if we have two
transactions one of them reads record ax
and reads record y
and the other transaction reads Y and
then X that's that's just a deadlock if
they run at the same time they each of
them gets this lock on the record it
first read they don't release till the
transactions finish so they both sit
there waiting for the lock that's held
by the other transaction and unless the
database does something clever which it
will
they'll deadlock forever and in fact
transactions have various strategies
including tracing cycles or timeouts in
order to detect that they've gone into
the situation the database will abort
one of these two transactions and undo
all its changes and act as if that
transaction that never occurred okay so
that's concurrency control with
two-phase locking and this is just
completely standard database behavior so
far and it's the same in a single
machine databases as it will be and
distributed databases that are a little
more interest to us but our next topic
is a little is actually specific to
building databases or storage systems in
general that support transactions on
distributed setting that is splitting
the data over multiple machines so now
the topic is how to build distributed
distributed transactions and in
particular how to cope with failures and
more specifically the kind of partial
failures of just one of many servers
that you often see in distributed
systems so beyond distributed
transactions and we're worried about how
they behave you make sure they're
serializable and also have sort of
all-or-nothing ad Amissah T even in the
face of failures so
you know I you know what the way this
looks like is that we may have two
servers and we got server one and maybe
it stores record X in our bank and we
have server two and maybe it's stores
record Y so they all start out with
value 10 and we need to run these two
transactions that transaction 1 of
course modifies both x and y so now we
need to send messages the database is
saying oh please increment X please
decrement Y but it would be easy if we
weren't careful to get into a situation
where we had told server 1 to increase
the balance for X but then something
failed maybe the client sending the
requests or maybe server the server -
that's holding Y fails or something and
we never managed to do the second update
right so that's one problem is failure
somewhere may sort of cut the
transaction in half and if we're not
careful cause only half of the
transaction to actually take effect
this can happen even without crashes if
X does its part in the transaction it
could be that over on server-to-server
to actually gets the request to
decrement bank account y but maybe
server 2 discovers this bank account
doesn't exist or maybe it does exist and
it's balance is already 0 when it can't
be decrease and so it can't do its part
of the transaction but X look has
already done its part of the transaction
so that's a problem that needs to be
dealt with so the the property we want
as I mentioned before is that all the
pieces of the system either all the
pieces of the system should do their
part of the transaction or none right so
you know the kind of the thing we
violated here is what atomicity against
crashes versus failure where atomicity
is all or not all parts all parts of the
transaction that we're trying to execute
or none of them and for you more the
kind of solution we're going to be
looking at is atomic commitments atomic
commit protocols and the general kind of
flavor of atomic commit protocols is
that you have a bunch of computers
they're all doing different parts of
some larger task and the atomic commit
protocol is gonna help the computers
decide that either they're all going to
do they're they're all capable of doing
their part and they're actually gonna do
it or something has gone wrong and
they're all going to agree that oh
they're actually none of them are gonna
do their part of the whatever the
overall task is and the big challenges
are of course how to cope with various
failures machine failures loss of
messages and it'll turn out that
performance is also a little bit
difficult to do a good job with the
specific protocol we're gonna look at
and is the protocol explained in a
reading for today our two-phase commit
this is an atomic commitment protocol
and this is used both by distributed
databases and also by all kinds of other
distributed systems that might not have
first looked like traditional databases
the general setting is we assume that
that in one way or another the task we
need to perform is split up over
multiple servers each of which needs to
do some part a different part each one
of them so for example because I'm set
up I showed here in which the it's
really the data that split up and so the
tasks being split up our incrementing X
and decrementing Y D we're going to
assume that there's one computer that's
driving the transaction called the
transaction coordinator there's lots of
ways of arranging how the transaction
coordinator steps in but we'll just
imagine it as a computer that is
actually running the transaction there's
one computer the transaction coordinator
that's that's executing the sort of code
for the transaction like the puts and
the gets and the adds and it sends
messages to the computers that hold the
different pieces of data that need to
actually execute the different parts so
for our setup we're going to have one
computer of the transaction coordinator
and it's going to be these server one
and server two that hold X&Y transaction
coordinator we'll send a message to
server one saying oh please increment X
send a message to server Y saying oh
please decrement Y and then there'll be
more messages in order to make sure that
either they both do it or neither than
do it and that's where two-phase commit
steps in something to keep in the back
your mind is that in the full system
there may be many different transactions
running concurrently and many
transaction coordinators
sort of executing their own transactions
and so the various parties here need to
keep track of oh you know this is a
message for such-and-such a transaction
and where they keep state like these
turns out these servers are going to
maintain table two blocks for example
and they keep state like that they need
to keep track of oh this is a lock
that's being held for transactions 17 so
there's a notion of transaction IDs and
I'm just gonna assume although you know
I'm not actually show it that every
message in the system is tagged with the
transaction with the unique transaction
ID of the transaction it applies to and
these IDs are chosen by the transaction
coordinator when the transaction starts
the transaction coordinator will send
out oh this is a message for transaction
1995 and it'll keep all its state here
about the transaction will be tagged
with 95 and the various tables in the
different participants in the
transaction will be tagged with the
transaction IDs and so that's another
piece of terminology we got the
transaction coordinator and then the
other servers that are doing parts of
the transaction are called participants
all right
so let me draw out the two-phase commit
protocol example execution so this is
abbreviate this to PC for two-phase
commit the parties involved are the
transaction coordinator and we'll just
say there's two participants that is you
know maybe we're executing the
transactions I've shown next and why
aren't different servers maybe we've got
participant a and participant B these
are two different servers holding data
so the transaction coordinator it's
running the whole transaction it's it's
gonna send puts and gets to a and B to
tell them to you know read the value of
x or y or add one to X so we're going to
see at the beginning of the tree
action that the transaction coordinator
is sending for example maybe a get
requests to Trent participant a and it
gets a reply and then maybe it sends
that put for whatever I might see a long
sequence of these if there's a
complicated transaction then when
transaction coordinator gets to the end
of the transaction and wants to commit
it and be able to you know release all
those locks and make the transactions
results visible to the outside world and
maybe reply to a client or a human user
so they were assuming there's a sort of
external client or human that said oh
please run this transaction and it's
waiting for a response before we can do
any of that the transaction coordinate
coordinator has to make sure that all
the different participants can actually
do their part of the transaction and in
particular if there were any puts in the
transaction we need to make sure that
the participants who are doing those
puts well are actually still capable of
doing the puts so in order to find that
out the transaction coordinator sends
prepare messages to all of the
participants so we're going to send pair
messages to both a and B
and when a or B would receive a preparer
message you know they know the
transaction is nearing completion but
not not over yet
they look at their state and decide
whether they are actually able to
complete the transaction you know maybe
they needed to abort it break a deadlock
or maybe they've crashed and we started
but between you know when they did the
last operation are now and they've
completely forgotten about the
transaction and can't complete it so a
and B you know look at their state and
say oh I'm going to be able to or I'm
not gonna be able to do this transaction
and they respond with either yes or no
so the transaction coordinator is
waiting for these yes or no votes from
each of the participants if they all say
yes then the transaction can commit
nothing goes wrong the transaction can
commit and the transaction coordinator
sends out a commit message to each of
the participants and then the
participants usually reply with an
acknowledgement saying yes we now know
the outcome this is called the echnology
all right so they all transaction
coordinator since I preparers if all the
participants say yes it can commit if
anyone in any of them even a single one
says no actually I cannot complete this
transaction because I had a failure or
there was an inconsistency like a
missing record and I have to abort even
a single participant says no at this
point then the transaction coordinator
won't commit it'll send out a round of
abort messages saying oops please
retract this transaction either way the
after the commit sort of to two things
happen of interest to us
one is the transaction coordinator will
mint whatever the transactions output is
to the client or human that requested it
and say look oh yes the transactions
finish and so now if it didn't abort a
committed it's durable
the other interesting thing is that in
order to obey these locking rules the
participants unlock when they see either
commit or an abort and indeed in order
to obey the two phase locking rule each
participant locked any data that it read
as part of doing its part of the
transaction so we're imagining that in
each participant there's a table of the
locks associated with the data stored at
that participant and the participant
sort of lock things in those tables
remember oh this is you know this piece
of data this record is locked for
transaction twenty nine and one finally
the commit or abort comes back versions
action twenty-nine the participant
unlocks that data and then other
transactions can use so we may have to
wait here and this unlock may unblock
other transactions that's really part of
the serializability machinery so you
know so far the reason why this is
correct basically is that the if
everybody's following this protocol
there's no failures then the two
participants only commit if both of them
commit and if I them can't commit if
I've them has to abort then they both
abort so we get that either they all do
it or none of them do it result that we
wanted the atomicity result with this
protocol so far without without thinking
about failures and so now our job is to
think through in our head all sort of
the different kinds of failures that
might occur and figure out whether the
protocol still provides atomicity either
both do it or neither do it in the face
of these failures and how we have to
adjust or extend the protocol in order
to cause it to do the right thing so the
first thing I want
consider is what it be crashes and
restarts
I mean power failure or something be
just some suddenly stops executing and
then powers restored and it's brought
back to life and run some maybe some
sort of recovery software as part of the
transaction processing system well
there's really two scenarios we have to
worry about one is B might have crashed
before ascending it's yes message back
so B crash before sending its yes
message back then it never said yes so
the transaction coordinator couldn't
possibly have committed or be about to
commit because it has to wait for a yes
from all participants so if B can
convince itself that it could not
possibly have sent a yes back that is a
crash before sending the yes then B is
entitled to unilaterally abort the
transaction itself and forget about it
because it knows the transaction
coordinator can't possibly commit it so
[Music]
there's you know a number of ways of
implementing this one possibility is
that all of these information about
transactions that haven't reached this
point is in memory and it simply lost it
B crashes and reboots so B just won't
know anything about transactions that
haven't haven't sent yes back yet and
then if the transaction coordinator
sends a prepare message to a participant
that doesn't know anything about the
transaction because it crashed before
sending yes the the parties will say no
no I cannot possibly agree to that you
know please abort
okay but of course maybe B crashed after
sending a yes back so that's a little
more tricky so wasn't in the crash
this wasn't a B gets a prepare its it's
happy it says yes I'm going to commit
and then it crashes before it gets the
commit message from the transaction
employer coordinator well now we had
we're in a totally different situation B
is promised to commit if told to do so
because the send a yes back and for all
knows and indeed the most likely thing
that's happening is the transaction
coordinator got yeses from a and B and a
sent a commit message to a so that a
actually will do its part of the
transaction and make it permanent and
release locks and in that case in order
to honor all or nothing we're absolutely
required it B should crash at this point
that on recovery that it be still
prepared to complete its part of the
transaction
it doesn't actually know at that point
whether you know because it hasn't
received the committee ette and whether
it should commit or not but it must
still be prepared to commit and what
that means the fact that we can't lose
the state for a transaction across
crashes and reboots
is that before B replies to a prepare it
must make the transaction state this
sort of intermediate transaction state
the memory of all of the changes that's
made which may have to be undone if
there's an abort plus the record of all
the locks the transactions how it held
it must make that durable on disk in
between it's almost always in a log on
disk so before B replies yes before B
sends the s4 in reply to a prepare
message it first must write to disk in
its log all the information required to
commit that transaction that is all the
new values produced by put plus a full
list of locks on the disk or some other
persistent memory before applying with
yes and then if there should be if it
B's your crash after sanity yes that's
part of recovery when it restarts that a
look at his it's log and say oh gosh I
was in the middle of a transaction I had
replied yes for transaction 92 I mean
you know here's all the modifications it
should make if committed and all the
locks it held
I better restore that state and then
when he finally gets a commitment nor an
abort it'll know from having read its
log how to actually finish its part of
the transaction so so this is an
important thing I left out of the
original laying out of this protocol is
that B must write to its disk at this
point
and this is part of what makes two-phase
commit a little bit slow is that there's
these necessary persisting of
information here okay so we also have to
worry about okay and you know the final
place I guess where you might crash is
you might crash be my crashed after
receiving the commit or or after both
you might crash after actually
processing the commit and but in that
case it's made modifications that the
transaction means to make permanent in
its database presumably also on disk
before after it received a commit
message and in that case there's maybe
not anything to do if it restarts
because the transaction is finished so
when B receives the commit message it
probably writes the copies the
modifications from its log on to its
permanent storage releases this locks
erases the information about the
transaction of months log and then
replies and of course we have to worry
about you know what if it receives a
commit message twice probably the right
thing to do is either for B to remember
about the transaction that takes memory
so it turns out that it B simply forgets
about committed transactions that it's
made durable on disk it can reply to a
repeated commit message if it doesn't
know anything about that transaction by
simply acknowledging it again and
that'll be an important a little bit
later on ok so that's the story of one
of the participants crashes at various
awkward points what about the
transaction coordinator it's also just a
single computer sorry you know if it
fails might be a problem okay so again
the critical where things start getting
critical is if any party might have
committed then we cannot forget about
that if any either of these participants
might have committed or if the
transaction coordinator might have
replied to the client then we cannot
have that transaction go away right if a
is committed but maybe its transaction
the coordinator sent out a commit
message to a but hadn't gotten around to
sending a commitment to be the crashes
at that point the transaction
coordinator must be prepared on restart
to resend the commit messages to make
sure that both parties know that the
transaction is committed so okay so you
know whether that matters depends on
where the transaction coordinator
crashes if the crash is before sending
commit messages it doesn't really matter
neither party if you know since the
transaction coordinator didn't send
commit messages before crashing it can
just abort the transaction and if either
participant asks about that transaction
because they you know see it's in their
log but they never got a commit message
the transaction coordinator can say I
don't know anything about that
transaction it must have been aborted
possibly due to a crash so that's what
happens if the transaction coordinator
crashes before the commit but if a
crashes after sending one or more
commits message then it cannot defends
action coordinator can't be allowed to
forget about the transaction and what
that means is that at this point when
that after the transaction coordinator
it's made its commit versus abort
decision on the basis of these yes/no
votes before sending out any commit
messages it must first write information
about the transaction to its login in
persistent storage like a disk that will
still be there if it crashes and
restarts so transaction coordinator
after receives a full set of yeses or
noes writes the outcome and the
transaction ID to its log on disk and
only then it starts to send out commit
messages and that way if a crash is at
any point maybe before its end the first
commit message or after its sent one or
maybe even after sent all of them if it
crashes that point its recovery software
will see in the log AHA which is in the
middle of a transaction the transaction
was either known to have been committed
or aborted
and as part of recovery it will resend
commit messages to all the participants
or abort messages whatever the decision
was in case it hadn't sent them before
it crashed and that's one reason why the
participants have to be prepared to
receive duplicated commit messages okay
so there's some other so those are the
main crash stories we also have to worry
about what happens if messages are lost
in the network you might send a message
maybe the message never got there you
might send a message and be waiting for
a reply maybe the reply was sent but the
reply was dropped so any one of these
messages may be dropped and need to
think through what to actually do in
each of these cases so for example
supposing the transaction coordinator
sent out prepare messages but hasn't
gotten some of the yes or no replies
from participants what are the
transaction coordinators options at that
point well one thing I could do is send
out a new set of prepare messages saying
you know I didn't get your answer please
tell me your answer yes or no and you
know I could keep on doing that for a
while but if one of the partisans is
down for a long time we don't want to
sit there waiting with locks held right
because you know supposing a is
unresponsive but but B is up but because
that we haven't committed or aborted B
is still holding locks and that may
cause other transactions to be waiting
so we don't want to wait forever if we
can possibly avoid it so if the
transaction coordinator hasn't gotten
yes or no responses after some amount of
time from the participants then it can
simply unilaterally decide we're gonna
abort this transaction because it knows
since it didn't get a full set of yes or
no messages of course that can't
possibly have sent a commit yet so no
participant could have committed so it's
always valid to abort if the transaction
coordinator hasn't yet committed so the
transaction coordinator times out
waiting for yes or no x' this messages
were lost or somebody crashed or
something
it can just decide alright we're
aborting this transaction we'll send out
a round of abort messages and if some
participant comes back to life and says
oh you know I didn't hear back from you
about transaction 95 the transaction
coordinator will see you oh well I don't
know anything about transaction 95
because it aborted it and erased its
State for that transaction and it will
tell the participant you know you should
abort this transaction too similarly if
one of the participants times out
waiting for the preparer here then you
know for participant hasn't received a
preparer that means it hasn't send a yes
message back and that means the
coordinator can't possibly have sent any
commit messages
so if participant chimes out here
waiting for the preparer it's also
always allowed to just bail out and
decide to abort the transaction and if
it's some future time the transaction
coordinator comes back to life and sends
out preparer messages then B will say no
I don't know anything about that
transaction so I'm voting no and that's
okay because it can't possibly have
committed started to commit anywhere so
again if something goes wrong with the
network or the transaction coordinator
is down for a while
and the participants are still waiting
for prepares it's always valid for
participants to abort and thereby
release the locks that other
transactions may be waiting for and that
can be very important in a busy system
so that's the good news about if the
participants or the transaction
coordinators time out waiting for
messages from the other parties however
suppose participant B has received a
preparer and sent its yes and so is in
somewhere around here but it hasn't
received a commit and it's waiting and
waiting and it hasn't gotten to commit
back maybe something's wrong with the
network maybe the transaction
coordinator is its network connection
has fallen out or its powers failed or
something but for whatever reason B is
waited a long time and it still hasn't
heard a commit now but it's sitting
there holding locks is still holding on
to those locks for all the records that
were used and it's part of the
transaction and that means other
transactions may be also
blocked waiting for those locks to be
released so we're like pretty eager to a
border if we possibly can or release the
locks and so the question is if B has
received prepare and replied with yes
isn't entitle to unilaterally abort
after it's waited say you know 10
seconds or 10 minutes or something to
get the commit message and the answer to
that unfortunately is no in this region
after receiving the prepare we're out
really after sending the yes and before
getting the commit it's your time out
waiting for the commit you're not
allowed to abort you must keep waiting
you must usually called block so in this
region of the protocol if you don't
receive the commit you have to wait
indefinitely and the reason is that
since be sent back a yes that means the
transaction coordinator may have
received the yes it may have received
yes from all of the participants and it
may have started sending out commit
messages to some of the participants and
that means that a may have actually seen
the commit message and committed and
made us changes permanent and unlocked
and showing the changes to other
transactions and since that could be the
case for all B knows in this region of
the protocol B cannot unilaterally
decide to abort at the times out it must
wait indefinitely to hear from the
transaction coordinator as long as it
takes some human may have to come and
repair the transaction coordinator and
finally get it started again and have it
read this log and see oh yes you
committed that transaction and finally
send long delayed commit messages so and
similarly if on a time I you can't you
can't unilaterally abort it turns out
you can't unilaterally commit either
because for all B knows a might have
voted no but he just hasn't got the
important message yet so you could in
this region you can either abort nor
commit
on a timeout and so this actually this
this blocking behavior is sort of
critical property of two-phase commit
and it's not a happy property
it means if things go wrong you can
easily be in the situation where you
have to wait for a long time with locks
held and holding up other transactions
and so among other things people try
really hard to make this part of
two-phase commit acts as fast as humanly
possible so that the window of time in
which a failure might cause you to block
with locks held for a long time is as
small as possible so they try to make
this part of the protocol very
lightweight or even have variants of the
protocols that for certain special cases
may not have to wait at all okay so
that's the basic protocol one thing to
notice about this that is a fundamental
part of why we're able to get to
actually build a protocol that allows a
and B to sort of both you know they both
commit or they both have or abort one
reason for that is that really the
decision is made by a single entity it's
made by the transaction coordinator
alone a and B are neither of them you
know except that they vote no neither a
nor B is deciding whether to commit or
not and they certainly are not engaged
in a conversation with each other to try
to reach agreement about what is the
other thinking or they thinking commit
may be all commit to instead we have
this much is quite sort of fundamentally
simple protocol in which only the
transaction coordinator makes the
decision a single entity and it just
tells the other party here's my decision
please go do it the penalty for that for
having the transaction coordinator
really the single entity make the final
decision again is the fact that you have
to block there's some points in which
you have to block waiting for the
transaction recording coordinator to
tell you what the decision
was one further question is that we know
the transaction coordinator must
remember information about transactions
and its log in case it crashes and so
one question is when the transaction
coordinator can forget about information
in its log about transactions and the
answer to that is that if it manages to
get a full set of acknowledgments from
the participants then it knows that all
the participants know that that
transaction committed or aborted that
all the transactions no participants
knew the fate of that transaction and
have done their part in it and will
never need to know that information
right as they both acknowledged it so
when the transaction coordinator gets
acknowledgements it can erase all
information all memory the transaction
similarly participants once they
received a commit or abort message and
done their part of the transaction and
made their updates permanent and
released their locks at that point the
participants also can completely forget
about that transaction after they send
their acknowledgment back to the
transaction coordinator now of course
the transaction coordinator may not get
their acknowledgement and may send and
may therefore decide to resend the
commit message on the theory that maybe
it was lost and in that case a
participant if it receives a commit
message for a transaction which it know
nothing about because it's forgotten
about it then the participant can just
send another acknowledgement back
because it knows that it gets a commit
message for an unknown transaction it
must be because it had forgotten about
it because it already knew whether it
committed or aborted okay so that's
two-phase commit for atomic commitment
for a little perspective two-phase
commit is used in a lot of sharded
databases that have split up their data
among multiple servers and it's used
specifically in databases or storage
systems that need to support
transactions in which records in which
multiple
records may be read or written there's a
lot of some more specialized storage
systems that don't allow you to have
transactions on multiple records and for
them you don't need it you no need this
kind of you don't need two-phase commit
if the storage system doesn't allow
multi record transactions but if you
have multi record transactions and you
shard the data across multiple servers
then you need to support either
toothpaste you need to support two in
pace commit if you want to get asset
transactions
however two-phase commit has an evil
reputation one reason is it's slow due
to multiple rounds of messages there's a
lot of chitchat here in order to get a
transaction that involves multiple
participants to finish theirs in
addition a lot of disk writes both a and
B have to not just write data to their
disk between the prepare and the sending
of the yes they have to wait for that
disk rate to finish so certainly if
you're using a mechanical Drive that
takes 10 milliseconds to append to the
log that puts a real serious limit on
how fast participants can process
transactions you know 10 milliseconds a
pop means no without some cleverness
you're limited to 100 transactions per
second which is pretty slow and in
addition the transaction coordinator
also has a point in which it must after
it receives the last yes they must first
write to its log make sure the data is
safe on disk and only then is that
allowed to send that commit messages and
that's another 10 milliseconds and both
of these are 10 millisecond periods in
which locks are held in the participants
and other transactions are slowed up and
I keep mentioning that but it's very
important because in a busy transaction
processing system there's lots and lots
of transactions and many of them may be
waiting for the same data and we'd
really prefer not to hold locks over
long periods of time in which there's
lots of messages going back and forth
then we have to wait for long disgrace
but two-phase commit forces us to do
those weights
and a further problem with it is that if
anything goes wrong messages are lost
something crashes then if you're not if
you're a little bit unlucky then the
participants have to wait for long times
with locks held
so therefore to face commit you really
only see it within relatively small
domains within a single machine room
within a single organization you don't
see it for example did you transfers
between banks between different banks
you might possibly see it within a bank
if it's charted its database but you
would never see two days can it run
between distinct organizations that were
maybe physically separate because of
this blocking business you don't want to
put the fate of you know your database
and whether it's operational in the
hands of some other organization where
they crash at the wrong time you're
forced your database was forced to hold
locks for a long time and because it's
so slow also there's a lot a lot of
research has gone into either making it
fast or relaxing the rules in various
ways to allow to be faster or
specializing two-phase commit for very
specific situations in which you know
you can shave a message or write to the
disk or something off it because you
know you're only supporting a certain
limited kind of transaction so well
we'll see fair amount of this and the
rest of the course one question that
comes up a lot this exchange here where
you have a leader essentially and it
sends these messages to the followers
and you know we can only go forward if
the leader can only proceed if it
receives you know acknowledgments
replies from enough of the followers
this looks a lot like raft this
construction looks a lot like raft
however the properties of the protocol
and what you get out of it turn out to
be quite different from what we get out
of raft they solve very different
problems
so the way to think about it is that you
use raft to get high-availability by
replicating data on multiple
participants on multiple peers that is
the point of raft is to be able to
operate even though some of the server's
involved have crashed or are not
reachable and you can do this in raft
raft can do this because all the service
are doing the same thing they're doing
the same thing so we don't need all of
them to participate we only need a
majority two-phase commit however the
participants are not at all doing the
same thing the participants are each
doing a different part of the
transaction you know a maybe
incrementing record X and B maybe
decrementing record Y so two-phase
commit all the train all the participant
they all have to do their part in order
for the transaction to finish you really
need to wait for every single one of the
participants to do their thing so okay
so we got you know raft is replicating
doesn't need everybody to do their thing
two-phase commit
everybody's doing something different
that has to get done two-phase commit
does not help at all with availability
you know raft is all about availability
you can go on even if some of the
participants are not responding
two-phase commit is actually not at all
available it's not highly available at
all if anything goes wrong we risk
having to wait until that's repaired if
the transaction coordinator crashes at
the wrong time we simply have to wait
for to come up and read its log and send
out the commit messages right if if one
of these participants you know crashes
at the wrong time you know if we're
lucky we simply have to abort then we're
not lucky we have to say did you finish
that did you finish that so two-phase
commit is not at all about high
availability in fact it's it's a it's
quite low availability as such things go
any crash can hold up the whole system
and of course raft doesn't ensure that
all the participants do whatever the
operation is it only requires a majority
there may be
minority that totally didn't do the
operation at all and that's how the fact
that raft all the participants do the
same thing we don't have to wait for all
of them is why raft gets high
availability so these are quite
different protocols um it is however
possible to to usefully combine them
like two-phase commit is you know really
vulnerable to failures it's correct with
failures but it's not available with the
others so the question is could you
build some sort of combined system that
has the high availability of RAF to
replication but has two phase commits
ability to call as various different
parties each to do their part of the
transaction and the construction you
want actually is to use raft or paxos or
some other protocol like that to rep
individually replicate each of the
different parties so then we would for
this set up we would have like three
different clusters the transaction
coordinator would actually be replicated
service with you know three servers and
you know we'd run raft on these three
servers one will be elected as leader
they'd have replicated state they'd have
a log that helped them replicate we
don't only have to wait for a majority
the leader we'd only have to have a
minority of these to be up in order for
the transaction coordinator to do its
work and of course they would all and
you know sort of execute through the
various stages of the transaction and
the two-phase commit protocol by
basically by appending relevant records
to their logs and then each of the
participants would also be a cluster of
a rep our raft replicated cluster
so we would end up and they would chain
exchange messages back and forth you
know we'd send a commit message from the
replicated transaction coordinator
service to the replicated a server and
the replicated B server and this is you
know this is admittedly somewhat
elaborate but it does show you that you
can combine these ideas to get the
combination of high availability because
any one of these servers can crash and
the remaining two you keep operating
plus we get on this atomic commitment of
a and B are doing complete different
parts of the same transaction and we can
use two-phase commit to have the
transaction coordinator ensure that you
know that either both commit the whole
thing or they both abort their parts of
the transaction you'll actually build
something very much like this as part of
lab form which you will indeed build a
shard a database where each shard is
replicated in this form and there's a
basically a configuration manager which
will allow essentially transactional
shifting of chunks of shards of data
from one raft cluster to another under
the control of something that looks a
lot like a transaction coordinator so
lab 4 is like this and in addition in a
little bit we'll be reading a paper
called spanner which describes a
real-life database used by Google that
users also uses this construction in
order to do transactional writes to a
database all right thank you